thank you thank you thank you
Academy countless for giving me this
award I felt very honored and excited
until I realized I had to make a speech
there was a reason I stayed behind the
camera seriously though I feel so lucky
to have had this wonderful life doing
the job I love working with some of the
finest directors of the last 50 years of
some of the most fascinating scripts
ever written and to top it off travel
around the globe to some of planet's
most incredible and mesmerizing
locations and can you imagine a job
we were actually paid to look into the
eyes of George Clooney Peter O'Toole
Richard Burton Peter Finch Sean Connery
Albert Finney Clint Eastwood Richard
Gere Daniel Craig Arnold Schwarzenegger
and those a 50 shades of grey himself
Jamie Dornan my back my life has been so
varied that I always say I work with
directors ranging from David Lean to
David Lynch so Carrie to Steven
Soderbergh and Sidney lament to Wolfgang
Petersen and many other talented ones in
between too many to mention
too many to upset that I didn't mention
them because you know how directors are
but I would like to thank them all for
the good times the manic and creative
times even those times they keep me in
the counting room until we are seven
days a week
I might mumble something opened in
cantera
sorry about that imp can hear incoherent
at the time but looking back I wouldn't
change a thing
but all those I still have to say my
greatest production are my three
wonderful and talented children without
whose love and support I would not be up
here today my two sons Anthony and James
Hickox are both right of Directors my
eldest Anthony has made over 30 feature
films and my Ganga's James isn't far
behind him having just spent six weeks
in Greece shooting lucky him and of
course in the middle of these two is my
daughter Emma who swore she would never
follow in my footsteps but so somehow
ended up a fabulous editor and is now
taking my jobs but we between them they
have gifted me four grandchildren the
eldest my lovely Olivia and then the
gorgeous a must - gorgeous Matilda and
Alexander and the newest arrival
Florence I like to call them my own
little dynasty so thank you once more
for this very special award I have to
say I never suspected I would be holding
one of these in my hand again I like to
think that I can share this with all the
editors the unsung heroes out there most
of us probably still working frantically
as I speak as this type of special award
reminds us that we do not do so entirely
unnoticed
good night may whichever God you believe
in bless you